我非常高兴来到这里。我之前做过几次分享，所以刚才一直在想，最糟糕的场次到底是哪一种？是卡在你们和午饭之间更糟，还是午饭后大家昏昏欲睡的时候更糟？所以我希望现在这个上午十一点到十一点半的时段，大家还保持清醒。其实我这场分享的副标题可以叫：保持谦逊，保持饥饿。那我们就一起保持饥饿，一起搞清楚，在一个任何人都能构建任何东西的时代，产品经理到底意味着什么。
我这里会比较宽泛地使用“产品管理”这个词。你也可以叫产品人、产品智能体、产品自主循环，随便现在流行什么说法。关于该构建什么、为什么构建、以及如何构建，我认为在我这二十多年技术行业经历里，已经发生了巨大的变化。
我想和大家聊聊我看到的一些现象，哪些事情正在改变，哪些事情又从根本上没有变。产品管理领域有一句格言，就是：构建人们想要的东西。
当然，就像我宽泛地使用产品经理这个词一样，我也会宽泛地使用“人们”这个词。我们甚至可以把它改成：构建智能体想要的东西。但从根本上说，一个专注产品的创始人，或者你们任何一个人的工作，都是构建一个真的有人渴望的产品。
那里有一个真实问题需要解决，而且人们真的想要它。如果你曾经构建过一个人们真正想要的东西，那种感觉非常强烈、非常身体化，无法被替代。
但这并不是我们花最多时间做的事。事实上，我们一直在发明各种有创意的方法，来避免真正构建东西。那边有人笑了。灯光的问题就是，我现在可以直接点到具体的人。是的，几十年来，我们一直在发明越来越有创意的方法。
来不构建东西。而其中有些做法在过去其实挺合理。比如两年前，构建东西很贵、很慢、风险也高。所以不构建东西在逻辑上是说得通的。事实上，很多产品经理，我两年前做过一次分享，当时说过：网上几乎有九亿九千九百万条结果，教产品经理如何学会说不。
产品经理几乎整个工作都变成了不构建东西。那我们是如何有创意地组织这种“不构建”的呢？如果你没有被这些图伤害过，那说明你还年轻有活力，我真为你高兴。
不幸的是，我被它们全部伤害过。我们有敏捷，有各种循环。这个可能是一个循环，有时候是瀑布，有时候又是别的东西。但总之是一步一步的路径，每个颜色都要过关。如果没过关，就回到零点，回到待办列表，或者回到切线以下。
我们有敏捷。我们还有一种东西叫 backlog，不知道你们还记不记得。我现在没有 backlog，我只有一堆待 review 的 PR，据说 Cursor 会帮我处理。以前这些 backlog 里装着很多想法，你不确定有没有能力构建它们。然后它们要进入会议，大家在电子表格里争论数字。再然后进入所谓 sprint。整个过程非常激动人心。还有 PRD，那种复杂文档，你必须在里面描述按钮怎么工作。
这说明十年前工程能力有多珍贵。工程师连按钮怎么工作都不能自己决定。不可能。你必须把按钮怎么工作写下来。这个东西，有谁认识？好，有几个人。如果你不知道 SAFE，那你真的还没体验过人生。但据说这是一种有效的软件开发方式。
然后现在我们又有了多智能体循环和自主编码。等一下，等一下。
我们现在全都在做一些奇怪的事情。也许它们是为了构建服务的。但我想挑战大家的是：我们现在很多东西，其实并不是为了构建人们想要的东西。它们当然是在服务“构建”这个动作，我自己也做很多这种事，也缴了不少 token 税。
但我认为这些复杂系统，本质上只是对工作如何发生的描述。它们非常像敏捷循环，非常像 backlog 流程图，也非常像不管 SAFE 到底是什么的那套东西。我认为这表达的是同一种冲动：我们离真正构建人们想要的东西仍然很远。
所以我们会发明其他看起来很有生产力的事情来做，尤其是产品经理，有时工程师也是。我们在还不知道最终产出是否有价值之前，就先做这些事。我认为这正是 AI 当下的根本挑战。
十年前，我们有 scrum、故事点和 backlog；现在我们有智能体群、token 拉满，以及全天二十四小时工作。我看到的情况是，Cursor 的朋友不能回答这个问题，你们把手放下。这个问题不是问你们。现在有谁写的代码比以往任何时候都多？好。那谁的收入增长和发出去的 PR 数量成正比？
好，再说一次，Cursor 的手放下。所以我认为趋势确实会变化。我们很喜欢谈论工作，尤其是产品人。我们太喜欢谈论工作了。不做工作，而是谈论工作，多么光荣。但我觉得很多这些现象，表达的仍然是我们过去见过的同一件事。
所以我想谈的是：我们现在真正应该做什么？为什么会发生这些变化？我们应该以什么不同方式工作？当某种意义上任何事情都变得可能时，构建出色产品到底是什么样子？今天早上台上展示的内容已经说明，可能性的加速正在越来越快地发生。我们应该假设，能力不再是我们的主要问题。
回到过去，构建很难、很贵。所以那些旧系统存在，是因为工程师是极其稀缺的资源。产品经理变成了非常怀疑一切的守门人。我们不只说不，我们还砍范围。
砍了非常多范围。产品经理的工作很大程度上就是保护工程产能。于是产品经理，甚至整个公司，都变得非常擅长这套漏斗，非常擅长对想法保持怀疑，以此保护我们非常珍贵的工程师。现在不同的是，这个漏斗已经不再需要因为产能原因而存在。
我们正在看到这个约束被打破。这是 Anthropic 发布的一张图，工程师现在每季度发布的代码量是过去的八倍。你可以争论这个指标是否完美，但我想我们都知道，代码正在被发布得越来越多。
大多数团队都在发布越来越多代码。一个人能发布的数量显著上升，一个团队能发布的数量也显著上升。而我认为，它很快会超过我刚才展示的那个优秀想法 backlog。所以约束已经转移了。因此产品团队、产品人，无论你是工程、产品还是创始人角色，都必须改变。
我觉得这就是事实。我们刚才问了，谁发布了更多代码，但收入没有随之上涨。我们看到的是更多、更多、更多的时代。我喜欢更多。这个房间里有人曾经为我工作，他们知道。
我喜欢把所有东西都发出去。我是一个 yes and 型产品人。Backlog？不用，谢谢。砍 scope？不用，谢谢。我想全都发布。而这是在 AI 之前。所以你可以想象，现在我拥有这种按需无限工程智能后，我会变成多大的噩梦。幸运的是，我并不孤单，因为每个人都在构建更多。我们都在做更多。
但我想你们都看过这张图。虽然 App Store 的提交数量和应用数量都在上升，安装、评分和使用并没有同步上升。因此，在所有这些过剩产能发布到世界里的东西，与第一张幻灯片里说的“人”真正消费的东西之间，出现了一个巨大的差距。
我们的代码并没有在市场中被大规模消费。我认为这就是当下雄心勃勃的构建者面临的问题。现在我能执行的事情多了太多，能想象的事情多了太多，能投入生产的东西也多了太多。这已经不是我的问题了。生产在爆炸，但需求并没有和生产成比例增长。
这不只是我们这些构建者的问题。它也要求我们思考自己使用的平台，思考我们如何理解要完成的任务，以及最终如何使用这些摆在面前的工具。所以我认为，我们拥有更多。
我们生活在丰裕时代。我们有 token 丰裕，有智能丰裕，有代码丰裕。产能更多，构建者更多，包括非技术人员。当然也有更多代码，多到我们需要更多 GitHub，至少今天我听到的是这样。总之就是更多、更多、更多。这一点实在太明显了。
但人们想要的东西并没有变多。更进一步说，人们愿意付费购买的东西也没有变多，而这才是我关心的。所以我真的认为，这是最基础的产品问题，也是这个时代最基础的商业问题：我们的产能没有足够的落点。
我们有整整一代产品思考者和构建者，是在一种完全不同的工作方式里训练出来的。而现在约束转移得太快，导致大家不知道该如何重新理解自己的工作、如何处理这个问题。所以这里有技能问题，有框架问题，也有市场缺口问题，因为所有这些产能就是没有地方可去。
好消息是，产品经理和产品人喜欢问题。他们特别喜欢问题。这就是一个问题陈述。他们喜欢问题。所以我认为有一些事情值得你聚焦，它们能帮助你从算力中获得杠杆，从代码中获得杠杆。希望我讲完这些之后，你们能带走一些基础步骤和产品实践，让你们多赚六百亿美元。
这就是我的目标。以后你们会说：我去了 Claire Vo 的分享，六个月后，她真的带我上月球。所以这是这场分享的目标。再说一次，代码是丰裕的，市场不是。这就是产品人需要解决的问题。
那我认为产品管理应该是什么？我直接给大家答案。它绝对不再是思考工程产能，那是一个很无聊的工作。我也不认为它的核心是原型设计。我觉得原型设计只是一个有趣的临时步骤，可以帮助你提升技能，但不一定是产品工作的核心。
我认为产品工作的核心，是找到方向，决定什么值得构建，并证明它真的重要。我描述这件事的方式和大多数人有点不同，因为我喜欢 ARR。
没错，为经常性收入欢呼。SaaS 的朋友们，给我一点爱。好，所以我认为“构建人们想要的东西”是一项工作，但这句话本身只是一个口号。什么叫有人想要？它不是说：哦，我有个问题，要是有人做这个就好了。那是个人软件，我们都会有这种东西。
我自己就做过一个三月悲伤专用的 64 首 emo 歌曲淘汰赛。除了我之外，它没有任何市场。它确实是有人想要的东西，但不是产品市场契合。所以我讲的是严肃的商业问题，真实的企业。作为产品人，在定义人们想要什么时，我认为你需要思考两件事。
第一件是商业价值。人们会不会为了这个问题付费？他们是否认为这件事在自己的生活中有价值？
是否愿意把这种价值转换成金钱。我发现很少有产品人会把这个问题放在第一位。思考商业价值好像有点不体面，但我其实认为这是这个时代的问题。是的，我们拥有所有这些智能，但我的假设是，真正的限速器会变成可商业化的想法，而不是我能不能发布这个功能、有没有人会用。
而是：我能不能发布这个功能，并且产生一种价值交换，最终带来收入？产品经理、产品思考者和创始人越能认真思考这个问题，越重要。钱并不总是自然会来。第二件事是：你能不能推动行为改变，让人们采用这个产品？
这正是我看到很多人失败的地方。他们能识别问题。
比如 Claire 需要一种方法，判断最好的 emo 歌是哪一首。他们也能构建解决方案：我们来 vibe code 一个淘汰赛应用。但我能不能让一百个人使用？能不能让一千个人使用？能不能让他们登录并投票？在功能可以按需从 IDE 里飞出来的当下，行为改变这件事被严重低估了。
我们经常看到一种想法：只要我发布了按钮，发布了命令行工具，发布了平台，而且它有合理价值，人们当然就会采用它。但我将近二十年构建产品的全部经验告诉我，这很少是真的。如果你能发布一个产品，并遇到一个真的会发生行为改变的市场，那其实非常神奇。
而不断拧紧体验、定位和分发这些螺丝，去弄清楚行为改变如何发生，是产品最难的工作之一，也是我现在很少看到大家讨论的事情。我看到很多人在说：如果这个东西存在会不会很酷，然后我就把它显化出来。但很少有人问：到底谁会改变自己的工作方式或生活方式来使用它？所以如果你作为产品经理只做好一件事，不，两件事，请做好这一边。
但我认为还有另一件事，是 AI 帮不了我们的，至少在我看来 AI 帮不了。那就是从第一性原理出发，显化真正新颖的想法。我非常努力地尝试过。
我非常努力地和 AI 头脑风暴。它能把我已有的想法变好，也能相当有效地探索相邻方向。但它并不擅长显化一种我认为存在、我相信可以通过行为改变实现、具有商业价值、但现实中还没有依据的未来状态。
我认为抄产品已经不再是优势，发布更快也不再是优势。真正的优势是对世界有一个独特愿景，能够清楚表达这个产品会是什么形状，并围绕这个愿景把它构建出来。
即便没有证据，也带着强烈信念去做，这就是产品经理的工作。我感觉产品人几乎让这块肌肉萎缩太久了。因为过去构建很贵，所以我们没有说：我要大胆地、在没有证据的情况下发布某个东西。我们说的是：我要渐进一点。
只有在有证据的时候，我才会为这个问题挤出一点工程产能。所以我认为这是大家需要重新训练的一块肌肉。没有任何模型会替你确认，你全新的原创想法一定会在市场上奏效。就是没有办法知道。当然，你也可以选一个很会夸人的模型，它会告诉你你是天才，一定会成功。
但产品管理里有很多事情，本来就是无法知道的。我有很多这方面经验。我做过一家实验创业公司，前排我的朋友知道，我做过一家完全围绕 A/B 测试的创业公司。我基本在世界上每一家 A/B 测试公司都工作过。你猜怎么着？有些事情就是不能通过数据知道。
而拥有信念、拥有愿景，我认为就是新产品人的工作，尤其是在产能不受限制的时候。最后一件我认为产品需要思考的事，是分发。产品并不止于问题和解决方案。我们都能构建问题，都能发现问题，也都能发现解决方案。
我认为我们真正需要思考的是，如何把人带上这段旅程。我们为什么都在这里？因为我们是 Cursor 社区的一部分。我们正在把人带入一段旅程，告诉他们：这就是我认为世界将要前往的方向，我希望你把自己的车挂到我的车上，一起前进。这不只是客户或社区，也包括队友和员工，甚至包括整个市场。整个市场都需要。
跟随你进入你的愿景，你才能把眼前的机会转化为成果。而我仍然认为，这是人类的工作。我曾经说过一句话：
魅力才是唯一护城河。真的，前排给我一点笑声吧。如果任何人都能写代码，任何人都能发布，任何人都能构建智能体，甚至很快任何人都能把数据中心放到月球上，那真正的护城河到底是什么？它是谁能说服。
谁能说服市场上最好的人才，谁能说服客户，谁能说服整个市场跟随自己的旅程，并投资于那个愿景。这同样是一项必须培养的技能。它需要在内部练习，也当然需要在外部练习。
我认为只要把这三件事做好：知道产品经理的工作是什么，把人们想要的东西拆解成商业价值和行为改变；在缺乏好数据的情况下，从第一性原理发展全新的想法；并且能够激励人们一路跟随你。这些事情会让你从所有这些代码里获得杠杆。
这些才是你需要做的事，是我们应该更痴迷的事，也许我们还应该为它们画一些漂亮的流程图。我希望整个行业能更多讨论这些。我想我们之所以不讨论，是因为它们罕见、困难，而且充满失败。但我确实认为，这才是优秀产品管理、优秀产品思维和优秀公司的真相。
那这对大家意味着什么？好吧，Claire，你说了这么多大词，具体对我个人意味着什么？这是不是说我们还会有产品经理？Claire，你说产品管理死了，那到底还会不会有 PM？我能不能把他们裁掉？工程师会不会变成 PM？到底答案是什么？给我答案。
几年前我确实说过，我认为 AI 会压缩产品栈。所以我当时假设，能做这项工作的人可以来自任何职能。他们可以来自传统产品管理，只要愿意调整技能；当然也可以来自工程师。我认为工程师被告知自己没有产品思维，这完全是胡说。也许你只是不想有产品思维，那也可以。
但我们曾经相信你们不能决定按钮该怎么工作，这个时代已经结束了。设计师当然也能做这件事。所以我当时相信，现在仍然相信，不同角色之间的边界会坍塌。但我也仍然认为，这些职位还有存在空间。所以我更新后的预测是：
人们仍然会招聘产品经理。你说了一句非常极端的话，两年后大家会说：他们不还是在招产品经理吗？产品管理并没有死。我认为 title 会活下来。组织非常习惯 title，公司也非常习惯 title。所以 title 会活下来。可是这份工作本身。
不会以原来的方式活下来。我认为产品经理的工作会非常不同。工程师的工作已经非常不同，并且会继续演化。设计师的工作也和我当年做设计师时非常不同。那时候我真的还在 Photoshop 文件里手工调圆角、手工做阴影。虽然这些 title 可能继续存在，尤其是在更大、更慢采用新工作模式的组织里，
但工作本身已经非常不同。尤其是产品人，尤其是和产品团队一起工作的人，如果你的工作感觉和一年前没有区别，而且你没有越来越多地关注这些事情，那我认为你最后会拥有一个非常庞大的代码库，以及一个非常小的公司。这正是我们都需要避免的。所以在这个任何人都能写代码、PM 已死的世界里，
什么仍然成立？我把这两个图标放在这里，因为只要有机会把我小小的 ChatPRD 图标放在六百亿美元的 Cursor 旁边，我就一定要放。但问题是，当我们所有人的工作、身份和技能都被压缩成桌面上的几个图标时，
那到底还有什么重要？我认为到最后，重要的是用户。作为一个行业、一个市场，我们谈论代码谈得太多，谈论基础设施谈得太多，谈论我们如何构建谈得太多。
我们稍微谈了一点在构建什么，但很少谈谁在消费它，以及为什么消费它。我希望我们能把所有这些智能，无论来自人还是 AI，都投入到这个问题上：人类行为改变、商业价值、世界上应该存在的新东西，以及如何让人们相信那个愿景。
当然，这不是说所有这些智能没有价值。再说一次，这个房间里有人和我共事过，我喜欢发布东西。我不是在说不要发布。大家觉得在这场分享期间，已经有多少个 PR 被提交 review 了？十三个？
我热爱这种速度。我也说过，快胜过正确。在产品经理和团队的工具箱里，几乎没有什么比快速把东西推向市场更有价值。
话虽如此，我认为你需要知道你的“粗制滥造大炮”到底要瞄准哪里。它要打向哪里？我们到底把这些 PR 射向哪里？我来之前和一个朋友聊天，我现在手上有 64 个 PR。
其中有些是不错的产品想法，有些是我已经忘了我们做过的东西，也许该做，也许不该做；还有一些肯定应该直接合并，已经准备好了。我认为我们正面临一种风险：发展出大量 churn 和 token 消耗，但它们实际上并没有在市场里落地。所以我真的希望大家思考，你要把这种产能部署到哪里。
总结一下，我认为你可以把 AI 当作盾牌，就像我们以前把流程当作盾牌一样。你可以用它发布代码，可以用它谈论活动量，可以发明各种花哨的构建方式，这都行。但我真正希望你思考的是，把 AI 当成愿景和市场影响力的加速器。
还有我最喜欢、也非常含蓄的东西：钱。我们做这一切到底是为了什么？如果不是为了构建伟大的企业，而不只是伟大的产品。我想我们已经看到过一家公司确实做到了这一点。越来越多人用这种模式思考，才能确保我们从正在使用的这项惊人技术中获得真正好的结果。所以这是我的宣言：产品人、产品思考者，去找到钱。
显化全新的想法，然后把人带上旅程。这就是这份工作。这就是当任何人都能构建时的工作。不要只是写代码，要构建，要构建公司。非常感谢。